[Music]
when it's cold outside there's nothing
like a warm bath to take off the chill
and these monkeys have found a great one
[Music]
the jigokudani valley in japan is buried
in snow for almost one third of the year
the area is more commonly known as
hell's valley named for its high
altitude jagged cliffs and bubbling hot
springs that fill the air with steam
the local japanese macaques or snow
monkeys have found an interesting way to
adapt to these cold conditions
in the early 1960s these clever and
curious creatures moved down from the
higher forests and tested the water of
the natural hot springs
they have been using them as a spot to
warm up in the winter months ever since
these snow monkeys like company their
average group is typically 41 monkeys
but can range from 10 to 161.
they're not picky eaters either they'll
eat just about everything from seeds
plants and fruits
or a handout from a mischievous tourist
even in the high mountains of japan
these clever critters have found a great
way to relax
spa day anyone
[Music]
you